foreign
this is what's left
after the
despicable human being banned the quran
in front of our masjid premises
this is the third time this despicable
human being lars tushan has come to our
masjid premises where we inshallah allah
are establishing the biggest masjid and
our center in the whole country is
and he has insulted the religion of
allah so today as you can see the
results here on the ground he has burnt
the quran with police protection
brothers and sisters
let's make this person this individual
the very reason for islam flourishing in
the country of norway
his message is that he wants to
extinguish the light of allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala he wants to
eradicate islam and deport muslims from
the country but alhamdulillah
this is the religion of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala and his subhanallah will
protect it and we muslims have come to
stay so
alhamdulillah actions they cannot harm
the religion of allah in the slightest
but what it can do it can generate in
our hearts the love for our deen it can
it can generate the feeling of
for our religion when he insults the
religion of islam when he bans the quran
when he desecrates this holy book it
creates emotions in our hearts so
brothers and sisters our role as muslims
is to be role models
we are not supposed to do anything wrong
the religion of islam teaches us to
respond in
in an intellectual in a befitting manner
so when this person is desecrating the
quran thinking that he can eradicate the
religion of allah extinguish the light
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as allah said you read
they want to extinguish the light of
allah with their mouths but allah
refuses except to
perfect his light even though the
disbelievers hate it so let's make this
person the very cause of allah
perfecting his
light for the spread of islam for the
islamic institutions to be established
so brothers and sisters we are
establishing this masjid he want he
wants to
prevent it he wants to stop us he wants
to see us fail so let's make him the
very cause of us insha allah raising all
the funds we need to build this masjid
to reconstruct this old building that we
alhamdulillah
have purchased so the next stage now is
to refurbish this building we need to
buy carpets for the floor we need to
build a member we need to build a mihrab
for us to start the masjid activities
let's make this person
be the financial
be the fundraiser for this project so
brothers and sisters from all over the
world donate for the sake of allah
especially in this blessed days and
nights of ramadan it could be laylatul
qatar tonight so
donate believing in the reward of allah
that you are defending his cause you are
defending the symbols of islam and you
are venerating the quran
allah